Okay, welcome to another Zoom call. It is the
East of February, a lot of people jumping in here. So it looks to be the way that we'll see
If you are listening to this
Remember that we can now do cheek swaps again right, but we're going through that
It depends on what you check the cheek swaps form. So please go to the member's site and look at them home page or
the cheek swab page or the testing page
All the information on doing cheek swaps is on in there the form that you fill out out there
Please pay if you can for the cheek swab testing on there as well. We have less staff
Ashley's not with us. It is not with us anymore and
So they're you know, everybody knows what's going on in Ashley kind of babies
taking to be a good mom to her baby girl
So if you could pay on there so we don't have to do the invoicing that would be one last step that Angie has to do
Of course you remember that you can get on any of the courses using your same username or password
and we updated the
Some of the top bar the search bar in such on the private
Evership site as well
Underneath the right. I can't do this because this is a screenshot
But underneath the right, but if you hovered over right here
It's got several pages to look at if you hover over care and you'll see multiple pages, which is
Which are the testing and we'll find your review and that and the
Cheeks swab testing and things like that other resources
And this is how you get on those in cost
We have the blog page you can access the blog page right there. No, we added that
That's the day of that today plus you have the search bar
So the blog page again, it was not on our regular website any longer
So there's on our regular website is very truncated. It's we had a short cut a lot of stuff off of there
because of the lawsuit
With the minister to board now the phrase god
The lawsuit with the video sort of board that has all been dismissed
So the only thing that they required us to do was to add
The bottle of every web page
Silly little statement that we already had out there, but they had to work in a certain way that
We don't practice medicine for the state of Minnesota. So
Just because it's ridiculous because it was actually the last that we already had
Just it's just
Make sure you search the blog here
For questions that you might have to I will be now starting to add to the blog
Some of our pages that we used to have on our website that we had to take down
Are now going to be on our full membership site. So this full membership site is going to get bigger and bigger
I apologize, but it will all be applicable to the search bar. So you've been searched through that as well
Okay, we have a lot of questions that involve multiple questions here. So let's get going here
Recently had restaged eat after nine full months of cutters clinic protocol still stage three colon cancer
Two there was seven centimeters now seven point five centimeters
New colon the sigmoid colons are confidential wall thickening suggests colitis
stable to
Minimally decreased lymph nodes a seven and all most very small largest went from nine millimeters to six millimeters
plead liver plead runs
Medical team recommended radiation with chemo pills followed by chemo
Uh
followed by surgery same recommendations as nine months ago and they definitely pushed you alone
Not too excited about radiation or chemo open to surgery, but with surgery alone there's a risk from that removing all cancer
If you follow all the recommendations pending no complications, they give you a 75 3% chance a success for five years continue with current protocol and distance the test is
15%
comments
So
Yeah, it's it's hard when you're given these percentiles with
Colleges because
They are such rubber numbers. There's so many people that
You know do different things aren't just doing chemo radiation of surgery
Drop off and it says I just don't know how they could actually keep
You know giving you projectile numbers now
Because the truth is you probably already knows somebody here that has had a similar cancer to theirs
That did everything medical oncology, you know, recommended and there outcome wasn't good
It doesn't mean yours won't be because you're doing a whole lot of other things. So
Again, I'm not against doing any of these things
um
It's you know, again the way I get the way I decide it for myself is that I
look at what their statistics are and
um, and then I you know, pray about it and say okay, and this is what I want to do. I don't want to do chemo
Let's say that that's me
But I'm open to doing chemo. God pushes me in that direction. So you really got to feel if you're being pushed or led in that
direction
I really I can't comment beyond that whether a person should do a medical treatment
That's kind of thing. It's a sort of struggle. So
I am two years post mastectomy ER positive cancer
And three years post hysterectomy for five weeks that totally different not cancer
taking IP6 to viral clear, which is a tumoric
Astro clear astro dim which is a dim product to decrease
I'm at astrogensal porosine which is a broccoli product
and to decrease um, that astrogens pectosol C
Which is a binder and it can grab on to circulating tumor cells. Do we copy it? I'm as daily
Great for stimulating the parasite the next
doing the right nightly left a toxic job
Interesting time out there
This person is recognizing that emotions play such a part in a person's health
If you're at a very stressful situation, whether it's a relationship or a job environment
What does that do? Cooks you in a sympathetic overdrive your parasympathetics go into the toilet and
You know, you need a parasympathetic, you know, stimulation or order to stimulate in immune response in order to stimulate detoxification pathways
So you're in this hyper sympathetic situation because of
You know the
environment to relationships that you're in it can be very difficult
Overall feeling well, but I've recently started having hot flashes. Okay. So why does a person have hot flashes
So women have hot flashes when they have when they're
Go through their change of life that go into a menopause and they're having a decrease in production
Of estrogen and progesterone by their ovaries
So while your ovaries start to shut down you could have hot flashes. Why don't
Why doesn't every woman have hot flashes? I know somebody who they went through menopause
And it was just fine. It never had any symptoms whatsoever
The reason is is that
If you have really healthy adrenals your adrenals also produce some estrogen
So the person that goes through menopause it has no side effects no hot flashes is a person who had very healthy adrenals
So that while their ovaries were shutting down their adrenals were giving them just enough estrogen to
Keep them from heavy time flashes now the issue is persons ER positive and they're taking things to decrease estrogens
Ah
That alone can cause hot flashes so
um
If you have an ER positive even though you're two years post-bestectomy and you've got a clean bill of health
You don't want to be adding
Things so let's say in person did not have cancer. No history of cancer. They had hot flashes. I would recommend
A product with or different herbs in it like black kocha should and macaroon
That um can help balance your estrogens and and um products that may be soy derived
um
Estrogen precursors
That can really help balance a person's estrogens to decrease their hot flashes
During that change of life, but if you're ER positive
History of the ER positive cancer really can't do that. So then what would I do?
I would use adaptogens. So as person goes on it explain other symptoms that they're having
And a puzzle symptoms. What would I do? That's a safe thing is use adaptogens
so and
You know that we have the uh
We have the
We have the adaptor clear
That's a good one. We also have the premier research lab
Um, I think it's called adapt
Agents are three
um
We have the several from for the molecular but they're not on the website since ortho-molecular doesn't let us put stuff on the website
We're seeing up a call in for that with uh, what I like best from them is the new adapt
uh
And then there are
And then we have also our court of clear, which is a good adaptor to so there's multiple adaptogens to choose from
Well, what should I do? I
If it was me, I would start with the adaptor clear
Start by taking three a day that can help you don't want to do things to help stimulate estrogen
The ER positive cancer. That's the problem. That would be the easiest way to get rid of your
You could be taking some
Estrogen precursors and you literally you could basically shut down all your hot flashes and such
but that could
um be bad for the cancer so you wouldn't want to do that
You must also test everyone for mistletoe. I'm assuming this is what in the cheek swab test the answers
No, you'll have to ask for that um, that is um
technically not a
Do-treative so the mistletoe therapy is injectable at an IV
Um, we use to when people came to the office we test for mistletoe whenever we go
Um, on a regular basis so that's something you don't have to ask for
So remember when you do your cheek swab testing
You fill out that form and you ask for whatever you want me to test you for
It's remember that cost is based upon time so if you get the list of 50 different things it's going to take a little bit longer to do
I have breast cancer that it has met to the bone right now. I'm taking zometa
Inclusion so so meta is a class of drugs um, this is the um, brand name
Of the drug
was the meta helps in
idea of zometa helps increase bone density
Now I
Zometa is a class of drugs that came out years ago a lot of 20 years ago, I think
and um, I have never been a fan of it um because
Well, I have to get too technical but your bone has layers to it. You have the outer part of the
bone called the periosteum
osteoosteum means bone peri means outer outer part of the bone periosteum
And then you have the inner part of the bone called the endosteum
The endosteum is really what you want to increase density
Um, that's what gives your bone strength not the periosteum
The purpose of the periosteum is for muscle attachment
ligament attachment that sort of attaches to the periosteum
You don't want to increase the density of the periosteum
You want to increase the density of the endosteum
The problem is is zometa and zometa like drugs are that class
Increase the density of the periosteum
This is very well-documented
Matter fact they started using zometa when it first came out for osteoporosis
The problem is several years after using it they did a five-year study on women
Using the drug and they found that there was no decrease in the amount of fractures
osteoporotic fractures
pathological fractures
Well, why is that? They're taking this drug that's going to increase the density of the bone
Well, they found that it actually just increases the density of the periosteum
Making hard and brittle bones
That, in fact, it gets worse because it's like putting celibate or sarandrap or all your bones
So you can't even absorb things into the endosteum
So I know oncologists are really big into using
Zometa infusions when a person has vets to the bones
It's just my opinion. I'm not a fan. I still think it helps at all
So are there things from a natural perspective that you could take
Yes, there is we have a bone-building bundle in our store
So we that is a bundle that we
use
That we recommend specifically for this is I think there's three different
Nutrition of products in that bone-building bundle
So you can look that up on the store
Started taking multiband. Well, that's a good start last week with ADK supreme. That's good
So the D is important to help get nutrition
You get calcium into the bone and the multiband has a good balance of different multiband
What I am ready to drop the eyebrows
False max formal shots of Zometa can I drop all at once
Or should I drop one at a time?
Can't really legally count it on that
um
That's something you're going to have to ask the prescribing doctor
on
I can't really say
I got a bottle of mimosa seeds to expel parasites
It says to take two pills a day
So mimosa is a product that we use a lot with our line patients over the years. It's nice because it kills directly
it doesn't work to
Stimulate in immune response, which is not good if you're in base three line if you have a bottle of immune condition type line
Um, so that's good
Um, but my probiotics say to take on an empty stomach just as this does
Does taking the seeds through in the effects of the probiotics
Plus the supplements I take the rest of the day by pulling them all in the body as well
So I think um
Is I would just try to leave it like 15 minutes away from each other and they may never even see each other in the back
So you'll be fine on that. I don't think we'll just get a damage
Your gut flora at all. I've never heard of that happening
We have used it very it's a very safe product and uh, I don't think it's gonna affect your
probiotics
I had a full body or biography done. It showed that my immune system is low
I'll send you the report so you could advise. Well, I want to comment on that right there because I know they
Lots of times they're radiologists where they look at fat. They'll say your immune system is low because maybe
You have some increase heat or decrease heat
around
I miss
That's just be honest. You cannot tell a person's immune system is low by looking at it as I'm operating so
That is just
silliness sorry, so
Uh, it doesn't mean your immune system isn't low
But I'll tell you you can't look at a thermography and say your immune system is low
So I wouldn't trust that
Uh, based on the above, I was going to try a 40-day fast. Well, I think it's a bad idea
So 40-day fast ever we've talked about this. Fasting more than 24 hours increases IGF-1 levels
Well for a person who doesn't have cancer that's a good thing. You want to increase IGF-1 levels
That's you will increase growth factors that will increase overall health
Doing longer fasts can be really good for you
Um
But if the person with cancer you really don't want to raise IGF-1 levels
um
So I personally would not recommend over a 24 hour fast with anybody with any history of cancer
You could do a fasting mimicking diet, which is a five-day fast, but you're not eat a true fast
There's been tons of studies on the fasting mimicking diet that shows that it does not raise IGF-1 levels
So it's safe for cancer. It's a very good for cancer
So the fasting mimicking diet is a five-day food plan
We sell it on other practitioners sell it. We have in the store
It's called the FMD. I have multiple videos on FMD
Um, that would be the maximum that I would say to do
Should I start to eat coffee animals now? Uh, should have started to eat coffee animals long time ago
But coffee animals are good for everybody unless you got
You know rectal cancer and you can't insert
The animal to there's different different people that you know, they just can't do coffee animals
But everybody else should be doing coffee animals. So yes, I think that's a good idea to do
Um, anything else I can do to boost my immunity
Really all your supplements your immune supplements are things that are going to boost your immunity
Plus coffee animals because what is there a logical
Stimulation of your immune system. It's your parasympathetic. So anytime you can stimulate parasympathetics
coffee animals are a great way to do so
um
Also look on the blog here. Look up parasympathetic simpathetic. I and you'll see all the
vagal nerve stimulation exercises and the sympathetic calming this metabolic
Exercise the calm the lesson cephalon where the part of the brain where the
Sympathetics are housed
Dr. C. Medici has a protocol for colorectal cancer which includes sodium bicarbonate
Enemies
I'm all full sodium bicarbonate Enemies for colorectal cancer
Um, personally I have not done them
Uh, but I would say that there is really no downside to doing them really
He recommends six days on six days off for four cycles with instructions on
The below website this website here on
And how to do that. What are your thoughts specifically?
The animals have you worked with this in clinical experience
I have we've had people do sodium bicarbonate enemies
um
I you know and everybody that works with us is doing a lot of different things
So I don't know
That there was major changes with that but you have a very good to personally ask this question as a very good track record of kind of
You know, seed
You know what's working and what's not working and kind of documenting their care
So I would jump on board with this a great audition plus the addition to your program
As far as that
I be sodium bicarbonate
I can't really comment on that. I don't know how you would do that. Your blood has all these buffering systems
I don't know if you could do ivy
I don't know
Have you heard of radio surgery done by doctor leader met in New York City?
Um, no, I don't know
That person so I have not heard that it's an intense type of focus radiation therapy that's supposed to be well tolerated
A lot less treatments a lot less invasive than regular radio radiation therapy is before that for pictures are amazing
I will look up his site. Thank you for that
Um, you know, this is the this is the nice thing about this group is we've had people that have used different surgeons that have really really like who've had people
do
Different laser mastectomy unfortunately the doctor that does that laser mastectomy is retired now
um
That um was less invasive and less damaging
Um, but there may be somebody else that doesn't so we used to have that doctor's information up on our website for
Our members, but we took it out because he retired
um
So I will look at this person's website and get this information up on our website if I think it's really good would be a good choice for some people
Okay, a long question here. I was research inside effects of horrible blockers that my oncologist wanted to use district like tumors in an article some women had
Memory fog for 10 years or more don't know how many people get the worst side effects, but after reading
That I almost prefer the breast surgery which requires massive reconstruction
They'll stop this because just because you have breast surgery doesn't mean that you have to do reconstructive
breast surgery. So you know, there's women that are okay without having breasts anymore. So
Does it mean you have to do the massive reconstruction?
Do you think I'm overreacting overreacting to the side effects? I think
Um
Yeah, yes, no, I don't think you're overreacting. I think you need to be as cautious as possible and it'd be
and work out this the way you need to work through this in your mind
um, I would caution you but just because some people have had this horrible side effects of something doesn't mean you're gonna have them
um, so
uh
Yeah, you know just
Take that into consideration when you're looking at this because you hear the worst of it
Understand that that doesn't have to include you even so
I don't know what to do
The only thing I can think of is to double down on the natural aroma chase inhibitors
Um, and that's what you're taking with the supplements right now. What's it you're talking about
But clear deal right now what kind of protocol can you suggest
That I can present to a collegeist as a compromise to reduce the tumors
There isn't a protocol under the sun
That you could suggest to your oncologist as a compromise. They're not gonna
They're not gonna accept that so um, uh, so I don't I don't think that is
That is something that
You want to get into an argument with your oncologist
You said last week that the estrogen itself isn't the cause of the cancer
So what else do uh, I have to take
More of so the tumor shrink as the estrogen diminishes. I feel like I'm running out of time before the tumor comes through the scheme
um, I sense your sense of urgency
um
And you know, you already are doing a lot of things and if your tumor is
Very noticeably getting larger or getting closer to the skin surface or bulging out
And you know, you do have to think about maybe adding some standards of care
I must
I must be ready if it comes through since I do not want to be rushed in the anything I agree
You don't want to be making
Decisions based on the emergency so you want to have time to think through these decisions beforehand
A holistic doc. I know recommended zymogen products
For natural holo balance myronase and uncle flex. So uncle flex with myronase is the product that we sell in our store too
Um, it's a good product
But I am still in favor of the so far as I by
um
By us enzymes is a better product. That is literally the same thing
But us enzymes has a reputation of having a leader product. I could personally know the doctor that that um
formulated the so far as I was friend of my um
Uh, and it took them a long time to get
Uh, took them over a year to find a source with the purest
um
uh, sulfur product with the purest myronase in it
So I would suggest the so far as I my us enzymes versus the zymogen
Well, I like zymogen products we sell them
But I just think the us enzymes are far superior product
I found a legitimate GC and AF source
Uh, through a trusted natural doc in uh, Michigan
Uh, if you would like his info, you could, yes, you could email it to me
That would be great who you're going to try that
Okay, that's fantastic too. It's another good thing to try
Okay, your questions are the chat
A good life was almost seen. I used brokola now um
So brokola under said he doesn't make any of his supplements
His are all private labeled just like ours are
Our name with our name on it are just private labeled too
Really the best life was almost seen now
Is the one from new medic and we private labeled that one
Um, so the new medic brand
It's because of what they use as the fact so
Oh, we call it
Uh, clear life was only see I think it's on our store
Um, it's sold in our private label as clear life was almost see
Or it's sold in the new medical label just like was almost see in the new medic brand
That's those are the best brands
I use there I use the that the clear curcuclear um, which is new medic as
Clear uh, new medic as life was almost curcumin
I guess I love that product. I take that all the time around
It really helps which is told about inflammation
Also side note there are private label glute clear
Which is like us over glutathione over the system great product to help
Um, just the detox pathways too. I take that one as well
With low dose neltrexone low dose neltrexone um 0.5
milligrams started out daily
Is the protocol to increase um after some time
Yes, so again, you'll have to talk to the prescribing doctor since this is a medication
But I can't tell you what is the typical dosage
Typical low dose neltrexone you start at 1.5
So I don't know why this doctor has you started at 0.5
The typical low dose neltrexone you start at 1.5 for a couple weeks
Then you move up to 3.0 for a couple weeks and then you move to 4.5
Put it in person to wait so if they're a TD person they might just stay at 3.0
But if they're a male of you know 170 to 250 pounds you'll go up to 4.5 million there
So I don't allow you're starting with something low dose
Let's ask for prescribing doctor
With mistletoe IV or objection is this worth tried
Um, yeah, I think it's worth trying
I the only thing I'd caution anybody about is don't try too many things at the same time
You don't know what's really helping you
mistletoe IV and mistletoe injections
A whole idea of mistletoe it's an irritant that stimulates an immune response
So there are side effects to that
So you'll get a fever, you can feel icky
There's a bunch different side effects that go along with mistletoe
And quite honestly that actually means it's working
So um, if you're doing mistletoe injections in your belly you do it above your belly button
And you're not getting this huge red reaction of this irritation
Then you you're not using your correct dosage
So you do you just just remember that
Uh, what does a 40 day fast do that is bad for cancer patients
Didn't quite understand the significance
It raises IGF1 levels
Any fast over 24 hours increases IGF1 levels
Which is a type of growth hormone stimulant
So um, you don't want access growth hormone in your body if you have cancer
So doing a 40 day fast can have negative
Now let's say I will say one thing I've had people that did a 40 day or not a 40 day
But didn't longer fast like a 10 day fast because they felt spiritually led to that
They felt God was leading them to do that
Well then by all means, listen to what God says, don't listen to what the research says
But um, the research out there is you don't fast more than 24 hours
Um, there's that's the research for um, cancer patients
Unless you're doing a fasted mimicking diet which doesn't raise IGF1 levels
For my recent Dutch test, my e1, e2, the total estrogens are below both menopausal range
Yeah, that's actually a good thing
So should I go off the sulfur as I'm for a bit? No, no
If it's not like a fact in you like you're feeling horrible
You just have no energy, you don't feel like a woman you have
Faginals right as you have blah blah blah all these different things that I'm super low
um
Estrogen no, this is what you want you are
Decreasing your
Estrogen load and I remember your your um test your 16 hydroxy estro was like super low
That was beautiful
You know, you don't want this you're right where you want to be
Also, it's at my
Phase one detoxification pathway from a metabolism. It's not ideal. That just means it's decreased. I would
Everything on your test was good except that
Accept the cortisol issue. So that's the thing that you're really only need to get address
I wouldn't be worried about anything else with that
I have to drink Kate farm protein drinks to gain weight
I get horrible gas from the drinks. They all make me feel below that any suggestions. Okay, so
So really Kate farm protein drinks aren't going to make you really gain a whole lot of weight if you want to gain weight
You have to eat more carbohydrates
Um, that's just the general rule doesn't mean that people are deficient
Can't be deficient in protein
Um, I'm not sure what's in the Kate farm protein drinks
I would suggest if you're going to do a protein drink that you use
That you use the um US enzymes brand
Sounds like a really tip of the US enzymes brand but um
But the reason why we
Carried that and we only recommend the US enzymes brand and they have a vanilla and uh or a chocolate
is because it's
low in
glutamate
So
I don't know what Kate farm's glutamate levels are in that
But the US enzymes brand chocolate or vanilla is low in glutamate a lot of our
Cancer members are using that it actually tastes really good in the shape too. It's I'm good
Um, and these are again the reason why I like US enzymes is the cleatness of the source
Uh, they are literally anal about their
Their purity of their supplement's more than any other company. It's on thing
That's why they have such a small line
Um because they're so strict with their their rigid with their requirements
Um, but and so fully answer that question
What do you do when you get gas
Or
After you eat anything, okay
Why do you get that? Well, the reason why you get that is because you have improper digestion
So now you could get gas and bloating because you just ate you know a chili with a whole bunch of beans which produced a whole bunch of gas
Um, and okay, well that may be not be a good example
But even at that how can one person eat chili and get a little bit of gas not so bad
And then and another person ate same amount of chili and they're just totally gassy and bloated
It's because of improper digestion
So the answer to that is you take a some sort of digestive um enzymes
With your meal
So you either take
You know digestive enzymes like US enzymes
Digestimes or you can take the HCl sign
By US enzyme
Um, or you can take our clear digest
Um, understand US enzymes paired company
Makes a lot of the enzymes that they then sell to most the other supplement companies
So most of the digestive enzymes in any good supplements are actually US enzymes enzymes so um
So if unless you're buying something at Walmart or something like that anything you buy at our store
We have the clear digest private labeled and designs for health. It's the US enzyme enzyme
uh, even now brand uses
uh, US enzymes enzymes
so um
H the HCl
Plus a digestive enzymes helps break down more fruit in your gut
Um in your stomach I mean and then the digestive enzymes help break down more of the proteins
In your intestinal tract
So if you're ever have bloated or a lot of gas and why am I getting that you have improper digestion
You need to start taking digestive enzymes which your food
If my breast tumor comes through my skin what do I do? Well
You have a lot of choices if the breast tumor comes through your skin
And you're gonna you're gonna be
you're going down a surgical route
most likely with an oncologist or
You could use topical things on it. So um
We have patients that have used topical like blood root sabs on their tumor. It gets very messy
It gets very complicated
It gets you have to be very diligent what you're doing and clean it
Um, I don't want to scare you away. We have some people that you know truly believe they save their life by that tumor coming through and they're using topical
But you have to be very diligent for a very long time
Um, and we have some people that you know even though they were able to treat it
Typically the tumor continued to grow underneath and it didn't work
So there is no perfect solution. So don't let any practitioner say
Uh, let's tell you that it is either standards of care practitioner or alternative practitioner. There is no perfect solution to anything
So um, you know, I know you are very anxious about that and very nervous about that. You are probably one that you
You know, you would have a more difficult time if the tumor breaks through the skin
I'm not trying to make a judgment there, but just by hearing your anxiety over that
I really think that you need to continue to investigate some sort of
You know, combination with standards of care
Um, and understand there's been people that have done surgery or remove their breasts and you know
That was 10 years ago and they're still going strong because they've done a whole bunch of other things like you're doing
So um, you may not have any of the negative outcomes on doing standards of care because you're doing so many
Other positive things. I just got a
I'm text message from Ann, you know relay that, you know, AJ her son with acute myloid leukemia very serious leukemia
Um, he's doing this uh
This protocol of chemotherapy that's very very strong chemotherapy. She just said he was sick for one and a half days last week
But it's back quickly and now with the break and no chemo. So um, he has to think five doses of this super super heavy chemo
This was his second dose and he's just but it was doing really well because he's doing all this other natural stuff
And using the right constantly so um, where you don't share that very often with somebody
do eat uh
Really really tough chemo. It's really not
So
Don't think you're going to have the horrible side effects that you listed back here in your question just because somebody else had this side effects
I have three foot bath programs one of them used to make the water black what I was done now what I finished this program the water is dark green
Uh, does uh, this
Uh, change indicated as well
If you looked up on the internet, you'll see that oh dark green. I mean it's pulling more out of your gallbladder
There's just not a whole lot of
complete
Science behind that so I wouldn't
Put any you know a whole lot of validity to that. Maybe it is maybe it's not we just don't know that let tell somebody
Is willing to take a sample of that and break it down to
On a granic organic chemistry lab at a nail and give it analysis of what is actually in there if there's any bile in there that I'm
Sorry, but I just have a hard time
Believe me that was where I think you just have to be careful with with um that information so personally do I think that's
That dark green as it is indicated anything quite possibly no not at all
Um could actually just be the different minerals that are in the water that change that color
So I wouldn't be concerned about that
Would you recommend taking zero I think you're talking a little zero light zero by zero light binder
Morty they're eating uh, I do my animals in the morning um
Uh, so it's different binders when should you take a binder how much should you take with binders
Um binders are things that you
You adjust that you
Absorb very little of it and it binds stuff in the gut so that you don't reabsorb things
So you really want binders in your gut all day long. So if you're um
You taking binders throughout the day is best. Is it better in morning or evening?
Probably the answers yes
It's better to have it in the gut morning to add evening so take some of the morning split up your supplements throughout the day or you're going to lose them
They all have a half length than you buy
So it's better to split them at the same
Okay, so if I wanted to try to reduce my breast tumors with natural hormone blockers
Um, what do I try? I'm only on the clear did now
I'm not gonna sit here and tell you that taking a whole bunch of natural hormone blockers is gonna reduce your tumor
But if you want to add to that you could add a robot clear
Type it in here
You could add a product that is called
Roboclear
You could add a product called astro clear
They're all a little bit different. So Roboclear has three different
um
deep estrogen
Decreasers
keylators binders
Astro clear is a lignin product that helps decrease astrogen
Uh the so for uh
The side by us enzymes is
the same thing as the
Uncle clear with myridase from
Disimagine that you asked about before but it's because it's a much better quality product
Um, um, so if you're gonna start with one of these I would start with this one and I would take
Um three to six per day if you really want to hit it hard
Um, and then the other thing that you could take that helps dislodge
So these are things that will decrease bad astrogens
And there's another thing that will help dislodge bad astrogens
From uh the receptor site itself
So the idea about bad astrogens and ER positive cancers is that the astrogens
Block this certain astrogens receptor on the cell membrane of a cancer and
That astrogens receptors actually an apoptotic receptor. So it's blocking apoptosis
The one thing that's been shown to help remove this is the highland 951
So highland 951 is a fermented soy. It's a liquid. It comes in a bottle eight ounces
And actually the manufacturer suggests that you take one bottle per day
Um now probably this is an expensive product. I think it's 59 bucks for a bottle. You're taking $59 bottle a day on that
Well, if you're really really really trying to avoid any medical things, you know, then you know, that's a choice to check or make
um now
We have people taking anywhere between one and
And six table spoons a day, which can be a third of a bottle
We have some people that are taking a bottle a day to try that for 30 days or 60 days might be a thing a choice to take
Another thing that I just did it talked about
last week. I just did an interview with the
product
The owner of the company
um that I don't think it's been released yet is is bettogede and it's higher dose is the paxalo
acetate um
I think it's called
um it's called paxalo
um
the teague
And it's paxalo acetate fMAS or something like that
Oh, that's in the higher dose. So this is a very expensive product too. It costs about
four hundred I think it's
five hundred dollars a bottle
But a bottle lasts you one month. So it's actually cheaper than the highlight that they've actually done studies on this with
breast cancer
The oxaloacetate this high-dose oxaloacetate take it as directed out of the bottles. I think it's their repills a day
The bottle will last you one month
It's a pricey product
But they've shown that it's teague it's taken stage for breast cancer people with whatever your revision
Now I just talked to the owner. He couldn't say that in the interview
So it won't be anything like that in the interview. That was called
oxaloacetate
CFS because the only thing they can talk about it with is chronic fatigue syndrome
But we actually have people buy it with with very very serious chronic fatigue syndrome and
post-COVID law law COVID because it's shown to take away those symptoms
and the
Metamorphath way that it's disturbed is
the
blockages that a person has in the crem cycle that pushes
Wishes energy consumption by for talk about this cancer energy consumption for
cancer patients
Into the warberg effect
So you basically are blocking the warberg effect so it can actually be theoretically could be good for any type of cancer
Originally the studies on oxaloacetate moronic
Astrocytoma and glioblastoma and now they're actually
I said I told everybody this last week that they're just starting a
Study with Mayo Clinic on glioblastoma with oxaloacetate this month
So
very promising
Nutri-sutico
um
That you could get just over the color
It's just a pill that you take. There's really no side effects then
It's just crazy
We have a couple people on it really haven't had enough time to see if it's really gonna make a difference
Do the drug hormone blockers work really fast to reduce tumors
People can take the drug hormone lockers and it doesn't reduce the tumor and all
So
People can take the drug hormone blockers and it does reduce the tumor, but I wouldn't say anything. He's gonna work really fast
um
I can't it's just
It's hard to give these
Clear black and white answers to the things is everybody's different and
How you reaction something is gonna be very different than somebody else. So
Do you know the body bounces back or be thrown into the metapause you will go into a medically
Induced metapause right away. That's how you know what's working. So
um
If you know that it's not working at all
So you really I mean that's the whole purpose of those drugs is to take away all your estimates. So
In regards to the extreme gas when eating greens. What is the best enzyme to take?
um
I would do the
the
HCL sign
This greens also have carbohydrates in them
So the digestive enzymes any digestive enzymes who themselves really are working as small and large intestine
and do
Most their work of proteins and fats if there's light pace in there too
um and you know
There's some digestive enzymes that also work on carbohydrates in your body. They're secreted in your chronic glands
um
But in your stomach you have HCL that's a pretty you don't some create any
enzymes in your stomach
HCL is a created in your stomach and many times
It's an HCL deficiency
That is probably the most common
deficiency across the board is an HCL deficiency because of our diets
Our stomach doesn't produce as much HCL as it should
And we eat way more calories than we should
And we end up with deficiency in HCL. So if you have any issues with carbohydrates
It really should be the HCL sign if it solely proteins that you have issues with
Then you could just take digestive enzymes
Reason why I like HCL sign is got HCL plus digestive enzymes in it
Plus our so does our clear digest. That's why we private label that I can't private label any of the US enzyme products right now
They're just too small of a company. Let me do that um
Then clear digest that we that we uh private label from um
Sides for health is got HCL and all these enzymes in this one
And as far as dole seed them as far as with the gas you have to dose these
Um, so you you start with taking
One per meal, okay, and oh, you know, that's not helping and I'd give it a week
That's not helping then you go to two per meal that's still not helping give it a week
Maybe three four or five days, okay, and then you go to three per meal
And I've had people have to get up to seven or eight per meal and it finally it takes away their issues
And then you start to titrate down
So you get up to seven or eight a meal of the findings is really really helping and then
You know, then you can start. Oh, I got to take six down. What I got to take five now
It is going to take and it's really dependent upon the size of the meal too
So if you're just eating something small you might not take 80
So that's how you're going to play with that dosage and then you're basically giving your stomach and your
Your pay creus of break by taking those and then you can slowly titrate down and oh, I'm getting that problem back at one
I'm going to go back up to two and you find what's perfect for you
Uh, you mentioned vaginal dryness which I've never had until now can vitamins be causing this no it's the decrease
In estrogen that would be causing that so
Um, and if you have an estrogen, you know positive cancer or if you are or for two positive cancer
You don't want to increase your estrogen
So that's where I'd go back to um, what did I say up here uh, go back to adaptogens
So adaptogens are going to help support your adrenal gland your pituitary
and
Your thyroid that's the beauty of adaptogens is just help balance it don't allow it to get over
Um, produce it will help keep that balance as best as possible
Can cancer cells become resistant to a supplement taken for a long time without breaks sure
Cancer cells could do anything that they want to do that's rule number one
I heard that from dr. V. I've been taking iq six since last year
Let's take it and take it a break. Yep, whenever we talked about pulsing
You can take a break and maybe go off a week go back on for three weeks off a week on for three weeks
Or you can pulse I gotta take it but it's your Friday. I'm not gonna take my supplements on the weekend
So there's different ways to pulse it
I have bettigied by a-o-r
100 milligrams is that the same
um
So bettigied okay, let me pull it out a little bit
Don't remember
doses
Of all these things
So you have the bettigied so the bettigied is um oxaloacetate and a hundred milligrams. Yep
That's that's where we were talking about oxaloacetate
So you have the bettigied bettigied is
bettigied understand the same company makes both of these just under the different label
So bettigied is the hundred milligrams of oxaloacetate all right
So the oxaloacetate
um
CFS is and this is and understand the bettigied is a hundred milligrams per
per two capsules so it's um it's two capsules per day gives
Honestly, I gotta go back. Oh, that's right. So the bettigied is
A hundred milligrams per capsule. That's what it is a hundred milligrams per capsule
But there's thirty capsules per bottle
The oxaloacetate is uh five hundred milligrams per capsule
And there's 90 capsules per bottle
So it is literally it's a lot less expensive to
To use
Um, not a lot, but it is less expensive to use if you're gonna you need to buy a whole lot of bottles of the bettigied
They just act they just literally formulated it to the study of how I'm taking
um
1500 milligrams per day
So if you were going to take 1500 milligrams a day of oxaloacetate
uh
CFS you're taking three capsules a day one of the morning one of the night one of the night
If you're taking 1500 milligrams of the bettigied you're taking five of the morning
Five of it new five at night a bottle is only last you two days
So you can see it's going to actually be a whole lot more expensive
So they formulated the oxaloacetate to last you above
There's um 90 capsules per bottle taken at three a day last to one month
So that's the difference. So a hundred milligrams is one capsule um
And if they're recommending um
1500 milligrams per day is what the study was for breast cancer. So
Hopefully that helps
It's a little confusing what the seller understands
So the oxaloacetate CFS is what it's called right now they can only label it for chronic
Fatigue syndrome the FDA came after them made down made them take down their their astrocytoma study
Even though they had a peer reviewed study for astrocytoma
Which is a brain cancer and they had peer reviewed study for breast cancer the FDA made them take that off
We can't put that on our site
It's insane
Okay
Lastly finally up to two scoops that packed us all a day and oh you're having trouble with that
Um, so I should be taking an empty stomach. I am not
I don't think you need to take your practice on an empty stomach. I've never said that
So I don't they say that. I don't think you need to take the practice on an empty stomach
Okay, yes
We sell both the betagetate and the oxaloacetate because
Not everybody needs it high dose. So
All right, well, we're
We'll close out tonight. Thank you all for being a part of this um, I
um
Know that um praying for you guys all you guys disordered and I just you know
You're always my thoughts of prayers and I thank you for praying for us
Oh, in case you enjoyed late our
lawsuit
Against us from the Minnesota board of medical examiners has been completely resolved a
Basically
Um, we came to an agreement, but they basically
Basically dropped everything so um, it's just it's totally a god thing
We just give praise and honor to him and don't know that your prayers have just helped
And we had to learn things from it too. I believe it got us sobered
We learned different things that we had to do differently to protect ourselves so that
It doesn't just happen again. There's somebody else. So
um
If you're in if you're not from Minnesota also um, you probably made out of heard
The governor's race governor Tim Walls who just one who defeated this medical doctor from the iron rage from way up north of
Minnesota um was running against so he was much more conservative as he was very outspoken
Against all the covid regulations um, well
Uh, he had the Minnesota board come after him multiple times. They're all dismissed
And now we've had a huge lawsuit um, like ours from the Minnesota board
Um, signed by the attorney general who he was trying to host as well
Just totally politically motivated. Please be praying for dr. Scott jensen. They're coming after him
They want to take this license and just destroy anybody that's trying to do anything good for people
So please be praying for him to keep him in your purse
Thank you all. I love you all and we'll talk to you next week. Bye bye